it looks so good why is she texting you
hey that's my that's my boss I know and
work hours are between nine and five and
lip babe oh my gosh it's 5:02
you want to go to classes polite no they
gave me a dirty knife there two years
ago it's cancelled babe are you mad
nope you're not mad no I'm fine
[Music]
so so we're we're good
I just think it's funny how you think
it's okay that she texts you at 5:02
and then you don't expect for me to get
mad watching you go working so hard that
we would love to come promotion
congratulations thank you
well does her daddy so badly they
deserve yes this is huge
I'm trying so hard not to be petty but
oh I don't want to be petty anymore help
[Music]
I'm just trying really really hard to
not be petty anymore you know what I'm
saying like trying to turn over a new
leaf Garak can't you see I'm trying to
have an emotional conversation with her
right now turn around with your hoodie
on you see how I am I just can't
help girl you are Petty Hardaway you are
petty labelled girl you are a petty [ __ ]
press rewind
[Music]